what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with Avengers versus X-Men
versus eternals with what is kind of the
conclusion in terms of the big event but
don't forget we have the Omega video at
the end of this kind of the aftermath
but in all honesty given the way this
story ends I don't feel like it's an
ending it's like I mean it is the ending
of the story but it feels like a move on
a chessboard right like you guys will
get what I mean but it feels like
Marvel's building up to something bigger
so what this does is this basically
leads to the progenitor kind of
initiating the end of the world starting
the process of wiping everything out now
one of the things that progenitor
Celestial was establishing was that the
world itself was pushing back right in
the sense that the world didn't want to
end and of course you also have the
superheroes who are fighting against the
progenitor itself now as for the world
we're not really given a whole lot of
indication there one of the theories
that some of you guys have come up with
is that it's actually the island of
krakowa like the actual Island itself
that is helping in its way to fight
against the progenitor but also remember
Captain America was brought back by the
five right by the mutants and again
that's something that they don't do they
don't bring back a human they only ever
bring back mutants who is part of their
Charter right they're very much
self-isolated but with Captain America's
return what it does is it starts to
Rally people and so for a Time the Earth
superheroes really have kind of Humanity
on their side everything is set aside as
far as a truce goes between the eternals
and the Avengers and the X-Men so on and
so forth things are kind of working out
well but what's ironic about this is
that there are a few holdouts here and
there for example one of the things we
talk about is this guy named Tom right
he's one of the humans that we've seen
in the story so far a guy with red hair
while the world is ending right
following the Judgment of the celestial
which really is too late for unification
or at least it seems that portals were
being opened by the eternals around the
world that could get people to safety
Tom chose not to take it and in fact he
kept his family with him and the result
is that his family and himself are
basically gonna die because of all this
right so literally his selfishness
doomed his family right doomed him and
his family and it's just one of the
those things where people are responding
in different ways some are hopeful some
are terrified some are very very cynical
but the thing about this is that with
Captain America returning when he comes
in one of the things that Nightcrawler
talks about is how Iron Man Jean Gray
the eternals or at least a handful of
the eternals that they are inside the
celestial itself trying to find a way to
bring it down and the response of
Captain America is that could work
unless it decides to change tactics and
it will decide to change tactics and
that's exactly what the uh what the
progenitor says like yes I'm going to
change tactics right like the reality
here is the Earth is fighting against me
I cannot destroy it with conventional
means or with the means a Celestial
normally would but I will simply go to
the reality Loom right literally the
core of the world and the thing that
keeps it together so what we're talking
about here is the equivalent of holding
a glass together with glue right what
the progenitor is going to do is undo
that glue there's nothing to hold the
glass together and it's all going to
fall apart that's what's going to happen
here right literally he's going to
destroy the world from the inside out
just obliterate the planet and he
literally does that right like rips the
planet open through a fissure and then
starts the process of destroying it that
way now on the inside of the celestial
this is where things get interesting and
this is where I say I think the ending
of this story might be controversial and
controversial insofar as like the ending
of a comic book I mean it's it's a comic
right it's a fictional story but the
thing about this is you end up having
like Iron Man right you've got Jean Gray
you've got all these guys here who are
consistently facing off against the
antibodies of the uh Celestial but they
finally get to its core right it's heart
if you want to call it that and when
they get there the virginiter just
doesn't really seem to notice them at
all may not even be aware of the fact
that they're there but it's basically
going through and trying to find a way
to end everything now what's cool is
Jean Gray because the because of her
tests and the fact that she'd failed
right because she was forced to really
accept the fact that she as the dark
Phoenix had committed heinous acts and
it's one of the things we talked about
in the previous video she was forced to
confront a reality she didn't want to
confront and the result of that is that
it made her angry it basically drives
her to lash again against the celestial
but that's when basically Ajax steps in
and actually takes Jean Gray out she
doesn't kill her but she incapacitates
Jean Gray and stops her and the reason
why is because from the perspective of
ajack this is all simply just a test
right this is all a test that's being
performed by the progenitor and the
progenitor even says I mean I kind of
stopped testing but I'm always watching
right almost as if it doesn't really
want to annihilate everything and so
what's kind of cool is that on the
outside you do have the Avengers kind of
doing what they can but you do have
different people out there but you have
like Humanity that's also unified
against the progenitor as well now
that's just the beginning because the
numbers are going to increase and in
fact it's really going to become cool
here in a second but what is going on is
Captain America approaches the
progenitor and says like sure like I
can't necessarily stop you but this is
your last warning you can surrender
right you can quit which is kind of
interesting the Captain America
approaches The Virginity like you would
a normal person and when the projector
says you don't have the power to stop me
the response to Steve Rogers is sure but
I can distract you and this basically
leads to a partially returned sign now
for those of you guys who miss the early
parts of the story when the initial war
between the eternals and the The
Avengers and the X-Men kicked off it was
really more the eternals versus the
X-Men what we ended up learning is that
the hex are basically these eternals
that are just ridiculously powerful
right and the reality is we didn't
really know about them before but
they're colossal in size now the hex
itself or at least sign itself is only
partially formed but sign is operating
as a vector and in fact a sign is
operating as a vector for the most
powerful mutants on Earth at this moment
right now the thing here though is that
sine is basically operating kind of an
allegiance with like Exodus because
Exodus was the Omega Level mutant that
initially destroyed son there was a kind
of a respect that built there and so
while science not powerful enough to
kill the progenitor it is powerful
enough to basically offer a distraction
and keep it from going through with like
destroying the world in the moment and
so what it does is it switches over
switches back to the inside of the
virginiter with Jean Gray and Tony Stark
and these different guys and what ends
up happening is Jean Gray you know her
initial response in trying to destroy it
is met by Tony Stark who actually ends
up becoming the voice of reason which
you would never expect
it's kind of weird to see that but it's
one of the things where he says okay
stop and think right and this was Ajax
point right say for example we kill this
progenitor Celestial right now do I say
we we kill this thing in his heart we
eradicate it then what happens the world
saved but all the billions of people who
were killed in his judgment they're
still gone right they're still out
there's no way to bring them back and so
initially it's kind of like okay well
then how do we pull that off because
Stark's response is there has to be
another way now this is where things get
interesting we don't see a lot of it
orcas gets involved now for those of
guys who don't know orcas is largely a
super secretive organization that's
composed of like Hydra Advanced idea
mechanics humans so on and so forth but
they're staunchly against and trying to
find a way to eradicate the mutant
population but they have Nimrod on their
side and they have Sentinels and what
would have been amazing to see is a the
tie-in comic where Nimrod and orcas and
the Sentinels face off against the
progenitor Celestial to see how they
fare because remember when it comes to
Nimrod he has the ability to analyze the
weakness of anybody he sees and then
adapt his powers to overcome that
weakness so there is a legitimate
possibility here that while Nimrod would
not be powerful enough to destroy the
Virgin later it could put up one hell of
a fight but we didn't get that and I'm
kinda pissed I will I feel like Marvel
should come back and just do like a
retroactive one shot right and just give
us that story because it would have been
phenomenal to see but the thing about
this is that where Jean Gray initially
tries to blow off the reactions of Tony
Stark and all that initially she's like
you know here's the thing it may very
well be a test whatever it doesn't
matter she tries to attract a virginity
and the progenitor of course disables
her attack and assess of course it's a
test right like I was questioning myself
but I have learned that you do deserve
to die all of you here on this world
deserve to die you remain creatures
guided solely by self-interest you
mutants would kill me as you have less
Stakes some of your numbers would cheer
as loudly as the humans cheered your
deaths those who hate you stand with you
only because there is no other choice if
there was they would take it and the
eternals even when free prove they
cannot change the overall statement that
it's making here is that there is no
unification it looks like it is it looks
like you guys have banded together unto
sing under a singular cause but you
haven't right you're doing it because
there is no other option right like
you're working together because there is
no other option you're not doing it
because you want to you're doing it
because you have to and there is a huge
distinction there and immense
distinction there right wants and needs
right expediency versus necessity that
kind of a thing right that's what we're
talking about here and that's what the
progenitor Celestia was looking for but
this is where things get really really
interesting Tony Stark ever the the the
rationalist right and even like the
eternals themselves what ends up
happening is you actually have Cersei
that basically broadcasts to the world
and she reveals the truth to the world
itself and what she says is that as
eternals the long kept secret that we've
that we've kept away from you guys or
the thing that we've always hidden even
though some of you are aware of our
existence is that every time one of us
dies one of you normal humans dies to
bring us back it's the curse of our
existence but we've known about it for
millions of years we simply just never
told you but now is the time for clarity
right if we are going to really step
forward and if we are going to be a race
that guides Humanity then it's important
that you understand both the good and
the bad of everything that we are and so
in in basically providing that
Revelation to humanity humans respond
exactly the way that you think they
would and it's one of those things where
literally Cersei was doing this just to
prove a point that eternals can change
they've been doing this for like
millions of years so that seemingly
discards the one reality or at least the
aspect of eternals that the bridgender
celestial held on to that eternals can't
change but in response want Tony Stark
steps up and Sony Stark says here's the
thing none of your judgments make sense
and this is one of the best things about
the story because it's kind of Kieran
Gillen taking the progenitor Celestial
and putting it in place of like cancel
culture or something like that right and
basically saying here's the thing you
have arbitrarily and for no reason other
than whatever reason you decided on your
own put yourself in a position where you
believe that you are a moral judgment
for the world but you're not but you as
the progenitor Celestial are an
amalgamation of us you are quite
literally created by us as just fallible
broken human beings which means it
stands to reason that your line of logic
or your ability to come to these logical
conclusions are just as flawed and just
as infallible for us as people right so
if you are as screwed up as we are then
who are you to make such claims as to be
some kind of absolute moral Authority
you're not right you're just a person
out there ranting and raving about
things that you don't agree with and
that's literally calling calling the
celestial out in that way it's not
enough to bring the event down in its
entirety but it isn't enough for the
Predator Celestial to actually listen
because there is truth in the words of
Tony Stark but then Jean Gray steps up
and says here's the thing you're about
to eradicate an entire world and it is
time that I come to terms with the fact
that I did eradicate a whole world even
though again Jean Gray obliterated an
entire star system right a whole solar
system is her coming to grips with that
and then in saying if you do this this
is something that you can't come back
from there's no undoing this right you
can't unring this Bell you will have to
live with this and if you are just any
normal Celestial out there it wouldn't
matter because it would just be your
role you wouldn't really care you would
have been doing it for ages and ages and
that's fine that's the role those
celestials play right Irish him the
judge and ziron the the the tester or
whatever that's their place that's their
role but if you do this you will be no
better than us right and you will have
to live with this for the rest of your
life and what it does is it actually
gives the progenitor Celestial the
ability to step back and look at the
situation now that's the controversial
part because I imagine people are just
kind of like really right kindness and
happiness is what brought this event to
an end yes and no so here's the cool
thing that happens right the progenitor
realizing that it's not really a god as
it sees itself right that it's not
really an absolute Authority coming to
this realization that because it is
flawed built by flawed people that it
cannot be an absolute Judgment of what's
right and what's wrong because the
people who built it don't have an
absolute Judgment of what's right and
what's wrong and its judgment is modeled
after their judgment and so in response
to that what it does is it basically
brings back everybody who was destroyed
right it brings back everybody who died
and then it asks the question like am I
worthy of living right like given
everything that's happened would you
judge in favor of me or against me and
that's literally when ajac judges
against it and when that happens it
merges itself with ajac and the two of
them are effectively reborn and then
take off to Avengers mountain now
following this with a day more or less
being saved Ajax does return but is a
whole new being she has a whole new
level of power but she's also one half
the progenitor Celestial so she kind of
speaks for it right now this is why I
say it feels like a move on a chessboard
Because the actual climax the event
itself does end with a whimper I won't
deny that right like I was expecting
some great big huge grandiose conflict
but honestly that grandiose conflict has
been happening for the last three videos
that we've made so you can kind of see
how this is just sort of the Tail ending
of it all but the thing about this is
that as the progenitor looks out on the
world what we end up finding out here is
that not everything has changed for the
better that where you had Humanity being
face to force its impending demise that
not everybody looked at those impending
demise as like this is a chance for me
to turn over a new Leaf for Tom it kind
of does to a degree right his family
lives again his son asks you know hey
like like you know what what happened
like I thought the world was ending and
he tries to explain it to his son but
he's trying to have more of a more
involvement in his family's life as
opposed to ignoring it but for a girl
named Katrina because of the fact that
she had sacrificed her life for all
these different people it wasn't some
Jesus christ-esque situation but enough
to where it was noticed by way of the
progenitor from Humanity that instead of
her being humble about it she's actually
become arrogant about it right that she
is she's a little smug because of her
actions like yeah man you guys all need
to bend the knee to me and because of
that what it shows is that a lot of
people out there are still really crappy
Humanity I wouldn't say Humanity as a
whole but Humanity still hasn't
necessarily learned but here's the big
kicker behind all this and this is why I
say I feel like something bigger is
coming which we do know that it is
because of like Thanos with mjolnir with
the Infinity Stones and the hammer and
leading an army of zombies because don't
forget that was something that uh that
Donnie cage teased in his early Thor run
like that's coming right Thanos bringing
it into everything again but like that's
that's that's gonna happen I just don't
know exactly when what we end up getting
here is in the aftermath of everything
there is a treaty that's formed between
the eternals and the and the mutant
population right so now they're working
together which means the mutant
population in whatever conflict that
they're in invoking the Treaty of the
eternals they have Uranus on their side
and remember in one hour Uranus
eradicated 98 of oracco on Mars a planet
whose population is 100
Omega Level mutants right literally just
all Omega Level mutants most powerful
mutants there he eradicated 98 of them
in an hour right so like they have them
on their side now now it's one of those
cool things because following that what
you also end up getting is the X-Men
that actually opened their borders to
the world in saying that with all those
people out there who died they didn't
back up every single human mind because
it wasn't necessarily their custom but
they can bring back sunk but it's more
of them sort of opening the idea of
Resurrection to the rest of the world
and saying like we're not going to do it
willy-nilly we're not going to bring
back just any swinging dick because you
know like you come to us and and you ask
us to bring back a person but you have
no real good reason for why that person
should exist we may or may not bring
them back right you know but if like
some person who was on the verge of
curing cancer just turns blue and kills
over from a heart attack yeah we'll
probably bring them back because their
work was was for the benefit of humanity
that kind of a thing but ultimately it's
one of those where it's it the story
kind of ends in a way where it is in
effect the progenitor Celeste you're
kind of standing out there and watching
out onto the world and saying like I
will never stop judging you a time will
come when we will enact this again but a
time will come when we will come back I
will come back and I will judge against
all of you or I will judge in favor of
you but all you've done here in this
Avengers vs X-Men event all you've done
was temporarily staved off Annihilation
that's it but once my judgment is fully
complete once the projector realized
that it wasn't able to effectively judge
Humanity over the course of a day once
it's like I will judge you for the long
term and I will compare your progress or
your regression in the future to your
current state now then I will make my
judgment accordingly and when that time
comes there will be no stopping me there
will be no way to Stave off the ending
of things that will definitively happen
and the Earth will either live or it
will be destroyed and that will be it
but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end thank
you all for watching and I will catch
you all later
peace